ми от тільки повернулися з лінії фронту
і військові і цивільне населення Хочуть
знати чим живе парламент І коли вони
чують інформацію що 200 млн грн
виділяється Верховною Радою України на
канал Рада в них одне запитання так А де
цей телеканал Рада ми бачимо що в
telegram-каналах на інших носіях уже є
вся інформація про сьогоднішнє
голосування і не можна тільки зрозуміти
чому ті носії ті парламентській бюлетені
офіцій Яким є канал Рада він не інформує
про діяльність усіх парламентських
фракцій на опозицію там повна політична
цензура і блок але він і Про засідання в
цілому не розповідає Ми хочемо
звернутися до головуючого На
сьогоднішньому засіданні і закликати
колег щоби ви ну проголосували за те
щоби канал Рада почав нормально
працювати як парламентський бюлетень